the idea we looked at this morning with
integers you remember that introduced
the idea is that numbers are about more
than just counting they are more than
just how big something is they can also
have direction right in fact that's so
important to what they've done this ah
thank goodness numbers have more in one
direction these are another name for
these is directed numbers so in some
textbooks and sometimes you'll hear a
teacher say this will get directed
number what they mean is another like a
new job which you go one way or in the
opposite direction so the idea of
directed number is super super useful
okay
we already saw three quick examples this
morning's of where if your numbers have
direction you can just black things
really actually what were those three
examples from this morning dream up the
three of money just the stock exchange
where things you know increase or
decrease in value someone give me
another one
yeah the Marriott Rick so it goes down
the Bobby ocean and you can come out the
to up nothing that goes up and Brett
okay so when we think out temperature
right we're talking about above and
below we tend to measure in terms of
zero is freezing point so in all those
cases you got up and down up and down
okay and that's where director numbers
are useful you might have looked through
that exercise right there up and down
are not the only opposite things you
could have say left this is your left
right euros if you just left and right
those are opposites has banged any
opposites you can see on our number line
here you guys have been number lines
before from white environment when
you're thinking about counting back and
forth so now you can see my number line
it goes in this direction and forever in
this direction because they can direct
weight so with your pen
and now again you can pick it up on your
number line I'm going to tell you about
the important features here so that we
can use this thing to help us right
firstly the most important number on the
entire number line is the one right
smack bang in the middle okay and that
number is zero very good thank you
actually might not exactly look but you
get the idea
zero is important because then you know
all the numbers to the left ah negative
numbers they go more and more and more
negative they might go down or left or
whatever it is one loss and all the
numbers on the right are getting bigger
and bigger and bigger
okay so what I'm going to do on top of
this is I'm gonna put a few markings and
maybe you want to do like maybe one
centimeter markings you've got a grid on
your book mostly so that'll make this
very easy and we're going to put a few
numbers here
so I'm actually going to put a whole
bunch of them right I'm gonna go one two
I'm going to fit as many as I possibly
can on my number line you might be able
to fit a few more maybe a few less you
should be able to fit a handful these
role item is on the right of zero and
then I'm here all my numbers on the Left
negative 1 negative 3 and negative 4 ok
so here's that you don't miss have a
physician that can go all the way the
instructions or that directly now
someone tell me why they are on the ends
of my number line why do we bother
putting hours yeah I mean my number line
it stops at 5 but you can keep going 6 7
8 9 10 if you guys have younger siblings
you know they might be at that point
where you ask them maybe might be like
20 and you know what they say nobody no
matter how much bigger their number is
you always just add one and you're gonna
be more I'd actually going to ask us to
make a tiny bit of a modification to
this knife line in a second general the
modification I'm going to make is we're
gonna add some zeros in these here's one
we talked about integers what I did is
it the nomads direction but in addition
to that like I said early twenty
something which shoes are has integrity
or as integral me that's whole so the
numbers that I've put on here they're
all integers but notice like a negative
1/3 then not whole numbers so you can
see they're not on my number line here
okay so what I'd like you to do - how
many help us demonstrate this tool you
can need a second I want you to add some
extra numbers onto here so instead of
faking this one let's add a zero and
make it ten the next one I'm gonna make
it 20 30 40 50 and so on
and that means over here I've got
negative 10 negative 20 you get 30 maybe
40 and the reason why I put this in here
is because the keys still work on today
is recognizing position so we can think
about the numbers and how they relate to
ourselves before we like to calculations
on these numbers
so for instance if I put a number a mark
right here okay anything that you don't
roll or anything like that but looking
at the way I brought mine online what
integer integer do you think could be
represented by my um my booth yeah it
looks like it's exactly halfway between
20th a right 25 let be like you know a
little bit off back that's precise now
on your number line I'd like you to pop
that in and you can see if you wanted to
say plot a number give me a number
that's somewhere on this not alone must
be smaller they don't fit yeah that's it
- 40 okay I can fit minus 40 in it so
someone give me a more awkward number a
number that's like in between the tens
unit 23 okay oh it's gonna be very close
to my 25 obviously should be a little
bit to the left though shouldn't it I'm
guessing it's pretty close in between
the important thing is you can see all
these numbers they're all whole numbers
you get it directly by looking whether
that